bassem un texte qui promet des débats
houleux à l'assemblée nationale
effectivement gavory c'est un texte
controversé c'est la conclusion d'une
longue période d'hésitation du
gouvernement cette loi sur le
séparatisme qui a été présenté ce matin
au conseil des ministres une loi
largement portée par gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur mais également
par marlène schiappa ou deux autres le
ministre à savoir le ministre de
l'éducation et puis le garde des sceaux
à l'issue de cette 12e conseil des
ministres cette loi a été présenté à la
presse dans une conférence de presse en
présence du premier ministre jean castex
qui a déclaré que ce n'était pas une loi
contre les religions est plutôt une loi
pour la liberté je vous propose
d'écouter le premier ministre ce projet
de loi n'est pas un texte contre les
religions ni contre la religion
musulmane en particulier c'est à
linverse une loi de liberté
c'est une loi de protection c'est une
loi d'émancipation face au
fondamentalisme religieux et plus
généralement face à toute idéologie ou
dérives qu'ils poursuivraient les mêmes
finalités
pour y parvenir le projet de loi
poursuit deux grands objectifs garantir
le respect des principes républicains et
le libre exercice du culte
sur le premier volet la loi d'hôtes les
services de l'état de nouveaux outils
pour renforcer la neutralité du service
public et garantir que les associations
respecte les libertés fondamentales des
mesures importantes sont prises dans le
champ de l'éducation afin d'assurer que
chaque enfant bénéficie d'une indique
d'une éducation conforme aux principes
de la république
l'un des grands textes du quinquennat
macron est sans doute le plus discuté
une loi qui divise que ce soit dans les
rangs de la majorité où dans les rangs
de l'opposition mais également au delà
des frontières françaises
un texte qui restera polémique
historiquement et diplomatiquement
parlant il a été renommé pas moins
trois fois il contient une cinquantaine
de loi notamment sur la neutralité des
services publics sur le contrôle des
associations sur l'obligation de l'école
à 3 ans ou encore sur le financement des
cultes de la loi était présenté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres et
la date n'a pas été choisie au hasard
par l'elysée car c'est la date
anniversaire de la loi de 1905 la loi de
séparation des églises et de l'état
côté elysée on évite un malentendu
surtout en cette période de crise
économique et sociale le coût de texte a
été présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres et devrait être discuté à
partir de la rentrée 2021 à l'assemblée
nationale merci sam shemie pour toutes
ces précisions direct donc du palais de
l'elysée